um the topic on my talk is why is it
slow we see many talks over the years
focusing on how to improve performance
in software but we don't see very many
talks about how to go about analyzing
performance problems or figuring out
um why is it slow
a little bit about me as you heard an
introduction I'm an engineer at capiche
capiche is a natural language
Processing Company and we're trying to
solve the problem of how to analyze
customer feedback at scale
I've made a learning science and video
course a couple years ago in 2016 which
is still pretty relevant today very few
people know that it exists because it's
only really available on the Safari
platform at O'Reilly
um and recently I also wrote a book on
async IO
the goal of this talk what I really want
to do is to try to give you a little bit
of my experience over the years trying
to solve performance problems I really
want to try and give you a strategy for
how to approach the problem
I want to give you a little bit of
structure for how to think about how to
approach this problem in different
scenarios but I'm not going to be
talking at all about how to actually
make things faster or any kind of
low-level diagnosis hardware issues CPU
registers and cache and and so on
so the scope on my talk is I've broken
it up into four sections the first
section is going to be on fundamentals
what you really need to be thinking
about when tackling a new performance
issue
in section two we'll talk about what you
can do when it is easy to run the code
when you can run the code over and over
again in your Dev environment
and you really have a great deal of
freedom in how you tackle analyzing the
problem in section three we'll talk
about when it's not quite so easy to run
the code
and some strategies you can use there in
section four we'll talk about
distributed systems and microservices
and how your thinking needs to change to
approach that kind of scenario so let's
Jump Right In
okay section one fundamentals
there's really only one fundamental that
I want to drive home in this talk today
the most important thing the most
important thing that you need to obtain
when analyzing a performance issue is
when the system is being slow what is it
trying to do
not in a fine-grained detailed way but
in an overall way you really want to
understand what the whole program is
trying to do while you're having this
performance problem
and I really want to emphasize that very
importantly it is super easy when
analyzing performance to try to focus on
one particular function or one
particular line and try to optimize just
that thing
but by doing so you miss out on a whole
bunch of enormous performance
opportunities where by changing slightly
the design of the program you can get
massive boosting performance
so I'm going to emphasize that again you
want to figure out what is the code
trying to do while it is being slow yeah
and you have to look beyond the current
line of current function this knowledge
gives you the biggest leverage to be
able to make a huge impact
you'll often discover in practice
that when you find the cause of a
performance issue that code can very
often be producing the same result over
and over like for example it might be an
initialization
um in the Modern Age with all these
machine learning models sometimes we
find that model initialization happens
over and over again at the startup of a
program and sometimes you are able to
save that result in case it and just
reuse it again on subsequent startups
the best outcome and this happens
disturbingly often is that sometimes
when analyzing performs Problem you find
that a slow path in the code is not even
required it may be there because of
Legacy reasons it may be that previous
people in the team worked on the code
several years ago and they're no longer
in the team and no one really quite
knows what the code does but when you
discover such an opportunity you can get
a huge performance boost simply by
deleting that code the best optimization
you can do is not to run a certain line
at all and this by far beats any kind of
algorithmic improvement
if you only focus on micro optimizations
it's easy to miss the really big wins
so long story short
really the the concrete thing that you
want to obtain when analyzing a
performance issue is you want to get the
call stack this is key
while the program is being slow you want
to see the line that it's currently busy
with or the function is currently busy
with as well as the entire call stack
all the way from how you got to that
line in the flow of the program
you want to know what initiated the slow
code and why because this gives you the
The Leverage to be able to make
strategic design changes
so before we get into more concrete
details I want to talk a little bit
about tools if you search for python
Performance Tools you will find many
many results and these stretch all the
way back the past 15 20 years
there are many Tools in this space but
for me personally my focus in this talk
is to give you a short list of the
things I personally use at work and in
my personal projects and my criteria for
what I choose to use really tries to
maximize the product of Simplicity and
impact
it has to be easy to use and it has to
be easy to get results quickly because
it's really easy to get bogged down in
very complex tooling where you don't
really get a lot of bang for buck
and by using some of those sophisticated
tools
and the final tip I'll give you in this
section is
instead of choosing the latest and
greatest tool and then finding out what
you can do with it it is much better for
you to First decide on the kind of data
you want the tool to give you and only
then select the tool that can give you
that data so I've already told you that
what I'm really interested in is the
call stack so I tend to focus on tools
that can give me that
so here's our first concrete section
when the code is easy to run and you
have all of your tools available at your
disposal you can run it on your Dev
machine
and you can throw many strategies at the
problem what is my go-to for how to
approach that scenario
local code is easy to run
you can run the program as often as you
like sometimes you do have to rearrange
things but having tests makes it really
easy to to run different parts of your
program independently so that's really
key tests are not only about trying to
prevent regressions
but they also help in performance
analyzes because the discretization that
tests provide can also be used for
performance analysis
for example if you're using the pi test
test Runner you can use the dash K
parameter to specify a particular
keyword that will narrow the scope of
the tests that you run
and I have frequently created tests
specifically to analyze a performance
issue not even intending to commit those
tests as part of the Version Control
System but only so that I can invoke it
using pi test and Pi test plugins which
we're going to get to in a couple of
slides
so my first big trick is something that
you may not have come across before but
the idea is that you can just use Ctrl c
as a performance analysis tool
this is by far the best bang for back
that you're going to get the idea really
is you run your program and while it's
being slow you simply hit Ctrl C
what you are immediately presented with
is a stack Trace
and distract the stack Trace tells you
what your program was doing while it was
being slow
in particular if you have a big skew in
the code that is fast on the cost and
the code that is slow
when you get the stack Trace after
hitting Ctrl C you almost always see the
same Trace
because that body of code is consuming
most of the time
Mike Dunleavy has quite a detailed stack
over for a post about this and he calls
it stack sampling if you're in a hurry
and you can manually interrupt your
program under a debugger there's a
simple way to find performance problems
you just halt it several times and you
look at the stack Trace if there's some
code that is wasting some percentage of
the time say 50 or whatever that is the
probability that you're going to see
that stack Trace
um that gets shown after you hold the
program
like it's too simple to actually work
but in fact it works surprisingly well
and in exchange for very little cost
um to you up front
I'll run through a quick example and I'm
going to be moving pretty quickly here
because I did a run through earlier
today of my talk and I ran out of time
so I don't want to spend too much time
on this I'm really going to try and just
hit the high notes on the concept
here I have a fake program that does a
few silly calculations there are three
functions F1 F2 and F3 and in the main
function we simply call those three
what we're going to do is we're going to
run this program and we're going to find
that it takes about two seconds to run
which is a little longer than we think
it should based on the complexity of the
code we're going to try to use our
approach of hitting Ctrl C during the
two seconds
and then we're going to see what happens
so what in fact happens is we do get a
stack trace and this is the stack Trace
that we get
and what you can see here is that we can
follow the status all the way down from
the main function which is the top of
the stack to where the function is being
slow so all the way to the bottom here
in F1
and in fact this function really does
take most of the time it's a Fibonacci
number calculation which is very
recursive in nature
and the interesting thing about this
approach
is that regardless of when you actually
hit Ctrl C during those two seconds you
get the same stack Trace every single
time
it doesn't even matter what the call
order is in our main function if you
call F1 f203 or in reverse order F3 F2
and F1 you still get the same stack
Trace back and the reason for that is
that F1 consumes all of the runtime in
this
City program
and this technique works surprisingly
well in a large variety of these these
ad hoc situations where for example you
have a a pi test invocation that seems
to take longer than it should you can
use this technique hit Ctrl C and you
will often find that you may have a
fixture for example that is doing a lot
of expensive initialization early on
so this is a really cheap way of
discovering a performance bottleneck
compared to C profile for example
I want to highlight the cost of not
having a stack Trace
the same program run under C profile
produces this output
it is true it does highlight the fact
that it is our F1 Fibonacci calculation
that is taking all the time and it also
highlights that it has large number of
calls but what we don't have in this
output is we don't have the relationship
between F1 and Main
these calls will just appear in whatever
order they sort according to the total
time and the per call time
and so on so we lose that link
so it's easy to see the time spent or
the number of calls spent but not why
not why that call is being made
the other thing to keep in mind is that
c profile is quite expensive to run
for this particular dummy program that
I'm using here the original runtime was
two seconds but when you run an ID
profile it was 74 seconds
in larger more complex systems that
impact can really burden you when you're
trying to figure out the the performance
behavior of the system
so just to summarize as your profile is
pretty expensive
it measures everything even things
you're not really interested in
and the worst thing is that
um
that table that we just saw when you see
the numbers presented in that way it
feeds the temptation to want to focus on
a micro optimization because you see
that a particular function is being slow
and that breathes the temptation to want
to make that function run faster rather
than thinking about the design of your
entire software stack
however C profile redeems itself because
it does actually collect the information
we need it just doesn't automatically
expose it in its default output so
another neat trick and the second and
final one in the section is pi test
profiling which is a pi test plugin
so the key thing is after you install Pi
test profiling this
command line parameter profile SVG is
really the magic
it's very easy to configure if you have
a Pisces suite and and call that
and when you do that
what you'll see printed in the console
output is this SVG file that's been
created
that SVG file looks something like this
it gives you a large map of nearly all
the functions that could run during the
execution of your tests and it has a
color coding for the cost so the warmer
the color the more costly that function
call is
and the colder the color the less costly
and I'm going to zoom in on a diagram
like this very quickly
it also gives you some of the stats that
you get usually in C profile output like
for example it gives you
um the total time and the own time that
was spent just in that function but it
also gives you the core stack because
these errors show the relationships
between all the function calls so you
can use those two pieces of information
to
um
gather quite deep insights about the
performance behavior of your system
however bear in mind this is a lot more
expensive than Ctrl C because it uses C
profile and C profile is slow
okay we're about halfway through I think
I'm doing quite well for time
so the previous section was when it's
easy to run the code locally in this
section it's more complicated
some reasons might be that the code that
you're trying to analyze makes a lot of
use of threads and sub processors it
might be difficult to run a narrow part
of the program
or you may not know which part to run
you may find in a particular scenario C
profile is too expensive to run
you're just not getting feedback fast
enough after making changes
and finally you may have significant
code in Native extensions and C profile
doesn't highlight any information inside
those
so my go-to in these scenarios when the
simple tricks no longer work is a really
magical tool called Pi spy
it really is impressive I have here with
these green check marks basically you
know a wish list of of all the features
that I've wanted in the past before I
found Pi spy about things that it can do
it's a sampling profiler it can attach
to a running python process so for
example you could use it in a production
environment if a process seems to be
hung or in a frozen stage you can attach
it and get get feedback
it has a very low speed impact it can
analyze sub processors it can dump call
Stacks on command which we'll get to
shortly and it can also include stack
Trace information from native extensions
inside interleaved inside the same
python extensions you would be used to
seeing
so let's have a bit bit of a look at Pi
spy it has three sub commands
um the three sub commands are record top
and dump and we'll just take a quick
look at each of those
so
the way to invoke it on the command line
is it it has a CLI called Pi spy and
then sub command which would simply be
record
and in this case you can see just like
we saw previously it's going to dump an
SVG file
and you can also add the dash sub
processors command
which will also measure subprocessors so
what that produces is a flame graph that
looks roughly like this I'm not going to
go through this in detail but I just
want to give you a sense of what you can
obtain with this tool
in practice you can hover over each of
these worms and you get additional
information and metrics and you get that
information about which function calls
are being made from which other function
calls and their duration based on the
width of each of these bars
um
okay moving on so pies by top it gives
you a view very similar to the Unix top
command but instead of seeing processors
what you actually see is
um
functions and file names in your running
Python program
as they consume more or less time
they'll change their order inside these
columns
and on its own this isn't that
convenient because you're not really
seeing a stack Trace you're just seeing
a measurement but it is super convenient
to be able to just attach this to a
running process
in certain situations and then getting a
very quick sense of which line the
current program is is stuck on
um and this final command dump this is
the one that is really useful
so again you have a sub command called
dump and you attach it to buy PID to a
particular running python process
and then what comes out is a list of all
the threads with the call Stacks from
all the threads in that running python
process
and as I said you can produce It On
Demand so you can execute your program
or you can have a program running in a
production environment and you can
attach this with the dump command and
then get an immediate snapshot of what
all of the threads are busy with
this is super amazing for being able to
jump in and get performance metrics
really quickly without very little
ceremony
and finally I just wanted to highlight
some other features that the pi spy dump
command has
it can show local variables and include
them within each frame in those call
Stacks that I that I showed in the
previous diagram
and
um you can add the dash native parameter
to include call Stacks from native
extensions those do need to be compiled
with an additional flag and that is
documented inside the pi spy
documentation but
um that is how you can have your call
stack from Python and from your native
extensions interleaved together in that
live dump View
okay and finally we're on to the final
section and this is the most difficult
one
in fact it turns out this is the easiest
one after all because you don't have
very many options to get good
information there's really only one path
to go down
just to clarify what I mean by a
distributed system you have a bunch of
services running perhaps and a bunch of
computers that are making Network calls
between themselves and the lifetime of
each of these Services running on the
different computers is all different and
they deploy differently and so on but
they do work together to provide some
overall service
they are much more difficult for you to
be able to run code at wool unless you
have a very small system
Services depend on other services and
those can also depend on other services
so it's even difficult just to reason
about the system architecture usually
and setting up a full Dev environment
for such a thing can be hard or even
impossible
and worst of all the performance
Behavior can be non-deterministic where
the slow Behavior can only happen
sometimes like maybe when only one user
does something or maybe when only one
kind of file is being processed by a
software and something like that
foreign
nevertheless the same rule applies the
Golden Rule the fundamental thing that
we wanted even in the simpler cases was
that we wanted to call Stacks because we
wanted to reason about what the entire
system was doing when we were observing
slow Behavior
in this case though what we really want
is a call stack that operates across
distributed Network Services right
we want to know which service called
which other service and how long each of
those calls took and we would ideally
like to see that
in an ordered relationship like a tree
distributed tracing provides that call
stack and it gives you timings for each
of those pieces
I have a definition here which I've
stolen from honeycomb
it's a technique used to Monitor and
observe requests as they flow through
distributed Services distributor tracing
provides visibility into each request
and all of its subsequent parts
there is an industry standard that has
been built up around these ideas
called open Telemetry and I have the
link here
there are many vendors that provide
tools that do this but at capiche we're
using honeycomb and I'm going to use
honeycomb in a couple of examples
so the key thing that you get from a
distributed tracing tool is a view like
this
you get a tree on the left so right at
the top here our Trace begins from a
Django endpoint which is the entry point
into our system from a front end
like a reactor a view front end
application and from this point on that
Django system is going to service is
going to call other services in order to
accomplish some goal so I've highlighted
here in red we can see that the service
name changes throughout the call stack
and in this example that I'm showing
here we have three services
but it can be more can be less
and these time-based bars that run
across tell you how long
um that particular step was consuming
and you can see these layered in a
nested fashion
there is a cost though for all of that
power
the cost is that this data needs to be
collected continuously you can't just
turn it on in an ad hoc way as we saw
with other tools
you have to add add instrumentation to
your software and all of these Trace
events have to be transmitted to in my
case the honeycomb servers
so that they can be rendered on demand
to set up such things is fairly
straightforward you typically would
initialize the system by providing an
API key which you would get from the
service
and
for things like Django and flask and
other similar Frameworks fast API there
is a middleware that can automatically
be configured to integrate into at least
the the rest API part of the stack
and then inside your code you have to
add additional things like this
for the case of honeycomb they have this
B line and client Library
um which gives you two main tools to
work with the one is a decorator that
you can attach to functions and the
other one is a context manager that you
can use to scope discrete blocks a code
and those two things work together to
send these Trace events to Honeycomb
I have a quick example of a case study
here that we really did use at capiche
where customers upload spreadsheets
which contain customer feedback data and
then we process and analyze those and
this screenshot is in fact taken from a
real issue on one of our
um issues in the issue tracker where we
were trying to process a CSV file and it
was incredibly slow
and um this might be too small to read
but this first big bar at the top is
about encoding detection literally just
trying to detect the text encoding of
the uploaded file and the second one is
to generate a CSV schema from the
uploaded file
and we found that we had a really
problematic code path that was producing
very slow results
and from when this issue was reported to
the resolution of the issue was within
one workday because we had these traces
available and I could immediately jump
to the tracing honeycomb and immediately
see that we had not one but two separate
problems and we were able to fix both of
those and resolve it really really
quickly
distributor tracing is extremely
powerful and I have a confession to make
I use this tool even during software
development just when I'm writing a new
feature or I'm working on a bag because
all the code is already there the
instrumentation is already in my
software so as I'm writing new code I
just configure a an environment on
honeycomb for myself for personal use
and then I send events to that and I can
analyze the performance even during my
development process using those really
nice graphics
in particular in Dave I trace all of the
SQL queries especially for Django and
for the Django orn because it's really
easy to emit way too many SQL queries if
you're not careful about how you control
the execution of those queries with
nested models and so on
okay so in summary
remember my advice is what you really
want to get when trying to figure out
and analyze a performance problem and
you're coming to that problem from a
blank slate what you're really trying to
get is a call stack because you want to
see what is causing the problem to be
slow through the entire stack right from
the from the start of the program
when possible
do give control c a try
if you have something that is running
slow on your machine and you want to
figure out what is making it be slow hit
that Ctrl C and you can get an immediate
stack trace and try to make sense of
what's Happening
if you need a bit more detail than that
if that's producing confusing results or
you have multiple issues that you're
trying to figure out Pi test profiling
is a much more comprehensive approach
which will give you that large tree of
of SVG that you can use to
um
check the performance of many functions
at the same time
if you have special needs where you
can't run the code
um
at will Pi spy is a really great tool to
be able to attach to a running python
process and it makes very very little in
performance impact
on that running process but can give you
real-time information
including cumulative stats through the
top command and the dump command can
also give you a call Stacks from all the
substrates in real time
and finally if you have a distributed
performance issue where it's quite
difficult to isolate the code to to a
single system you will have to use a
tracing system like honeycomb to be able
to analyze performance and that will
require upfront instrumentation of your
code in order to emit those events
I know that I have left out a huge
number of tools and I'm sure
other people would have their own
um suggestions for what what will work
well for them but this is the set that I
currently use so these are my go-to
options for the different scenarios that
I've highlighted
and that is the end of my talk
thank you everyone for attending